I fully acknowledge that I'm not
thinking big enough for where I want to
go every time I think I'm thinking big
or watch an Elon Musk video and Elon
Musk is talking about having a backup
plan for the planet that's why we're
going to Mars I watch a Steve Jobs video
about taking a dent in the universe and
I realized oh my gosh I'm thinking so
small I'm doing nothing not in a bad way
in an inspiring positive way to say man
you could be doing so much more come on
man let's go so it's still my biggest
problem too it's the hardest thing to
catch because for him and his
environment and his friends and how he
grew up a points run is correct thinking
getting the discount codes is the right
thinking the challenge with that is
you're spending time looking for the
best deal and looking to save $100 here
or couple hundred there and you're using
your mental energy up on small problems